ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences Janet yang
[Music]
hello everyone good evening and welcome
to the 2023 scientific and Technical
Awards
the last
the last time we were together for this
ceremony in person was February of 2019.
so much has occurred over the past four
years so many incredible films have come
to life as well that's what makes
tonight all the more special
I know many of you traveled far and wide
to be with us and I'm just sorry we
couldn't deliver the weather that Los
Angeles is typically known for
fortunately we have this beautiful space
together and I can't think of a more
fitting venue to make a triumphant
return than right here at our very own
Academy Museum of motion pictures
foreign
just as this Museum stands as a tribute
to and an education center committed to
honoring film history this evening
serves as both a celebration of the past
and a welcoming Embrace of the future
and there is a lot to celebrate along
with presenting Awards to 20 recipients
for the work they've already done we
recognize how their dedication to the
Art and Science of movie making paves
the way for what's to come
and if we want we are to see excuse me
if what we are to see tonight is any
indication I'm confident that the magic
of Motion Pictures will continue to
flourish in full UHD with millions of
colors how many K's
who knows but anything's possible with
the Stellar talent in this theater
before we dive into the program I'd just
like to say a few words to our honorees
like many people I go to the movies to
be whisked away from reality to feel and
experience the universe that the
characters inhabit while I confess to
not fully understanding how the codes
and cables the voxels and pixels connect
what I do know is that each of you is
responsible for making it all work and I
applaud you as president of the academy
I'm attending my first scitec awards and
so honored to be here with you as a
lover of movies I am in awe of the work
you do and I want to continually educate
myself as well as all of the academic
Academy members on your extraordinary
contributions to the Art and Science of
Cinema
congratulations on your achievements and
please enjoy this evening